i don't know how to start podcasts in
the new studio i feel like we need to
have a new way to start except just
horribly singing our
intro song which i've been meaning to
change for a year
how should we benton is not here just
everyone uh off the bat um we're both
wearing benton's clothes
but benjamin is not here
benton he has coveted um so ben is not
here we are
trudging forward uh anyway in a studio
that's not complete yet if you're
watching this we look like we're in pp's
playhouse
if you're listening to this we're in the
old one yeah we are redoing the podcast
studio it's gonna look so cool um and i
have it as you can see behind me there's
all these like nooks and shelves and
stuff for my beverages only so this one
these i originally intended them for uh
gifts that fans of the podcast sent and
made for us but i'm probably let's be
honest just going to fill them with a
bunch of empty cans and lotions and
lubes and oils
in a variety of different uh oils so
uh i do want to oh introduce our guest
because new year new me um 20 20 20 20
20 bitch
[Laughter]
i did post on instagram fucking new new
year new me 2020 you're gonna be my best
get it bitch 2020 but it wasn't a joke
it was 20 22. i got it we're now going
to introduce the guests because i'm not
going to force you to google them and
mess up your algorithm because it's not
like you're already on a device yeah
well because yeah if you
if you do google our guests you're going
to end up getting recommended some
really fucked up videos
in your discover page so um sam morelle
brilliant comedian
his sp he has had a special called
positive influence the other one i just
want to make sure i get where they all
are on right um because everyone's
getting d platform these days so i just
want to make sure he's still on
everyone's shadow band yeah uh his
special i got this is on youtube still
and then he did a documentary about
comedy the pandemic that was on youtube
as well for now
for now i don't even know if we're on
youtube anymore i made a q a joke off
camera so who knows if they'll uh let us
uh keep going but we have we're doing an
emergency real quick conversation about
elizabeth holmes
because she has been convicted on four
counts out of the 11 right not even that
many by the way that's a different
conversation for another day but i'm
obsessed with elizabeth holmes you know
i love con artists that's why i work
with emily uh i am the elizabeth holmes
of comedy we all know this
you think i worked for lauren michaels i
worked for michael's the crash
the craft store
by the way you'd be better qualified for
this job because you can help me with
these fucking shelves
honestly i need to see
the microphone is falling apart in my
hands i would rather i need someone that
works everybody knows how to work a hot
glue gun
to glue my fucking eyelashes back on my
head
can it get someone that worked at
michael's who's great with plaster of
paris come fix my under eye bags finally
this worked out my favor
okay so i just want to talk about
elizabeth holmes uh because i just have
so many thoughts and i can't put it into
twitter tweets because people just get
too crazy and they're like how dare you
criticize a woman or if you do make a
joke they're like this isn't anything to
joke about it's blood like blood is the
funniest shit ever and again
2022 mantra the show is still blood is
not lube it's just so rare that
everyone's obsessed with the same person
i'm obsessed with like i'm always
obsessed with really esoteric people
that no one wants to talk about right
right like isadora duncan yep and like
naomi wolf yeah and like steve wins
scooch guy
and so i'm so excited that someone that
i am been thinking about non-stop for
the past five years is actually in the
zeitgeist that's so funny my m okay so
she scammed okay the whole thing with
walgreens i just it is so funny to me
that everyone is so mad that the
theranos devices were in walgreens
because of all the products in walgreens
where we need to sue the people that
made them
to me the theranost device doesn't break
like the top 200.
okay this is the theranost device was
like the least dangerous product at
walgreens like if you if you wanna i've
been drawing blood and walgreens for
years
okay
if you want to try blood and walgreens
buy a walgreens razor dude
theranos literally is it the whole thing
is crazy to me it's like
it happened because you're afraid of
needles right in walgreens right have
you ever brought a walgreens hairbrush
it's just made of needles
they don't even have the little plastic
like nubs on the end
like i've drawn more blood on walgreens
like the saran wrap like mini shark
teeth
than anyone did on this blood machine
dude okay like the fact that we're mad
at a 19 year old easy bake oven
when walgreens sells
pop-off vodka
with a plastic jug with a handle right
next to the pharmacy dude
that papa vodka that should be in the
fucking car maintenance aisle
like walgreens dude like a year ago i
got keebler elves remember magic middles
yeah yeah imagine i bought them at
walgreens ate the entire bag
that shit's been off the market for like
20 years
i looked it up dude i was like wait a
second i thought these were discontinued
they were
like walgreens dude walgreens christmas
popcorn
okay
you're fine with the walgreens tub of
christmas popcorn but like the fake
needle that doesn't do anything that's
what you're upset about
i mean is okay these needles we're gonna
go to afghanistan the needle machine as
long as the christmas popcorn doesn't go
to our troops we're gonna be fine those
things are like a wet market and a fun
tin i'm not
walgreens night dude walgreens sleep
stuff walgreens nyquil like the
walgreens bread nyquil
that's why elizabeth holmes couldn't
remember anything at the trial she took
one of those eight years ago
to try to get some sleep before
conference
i'm also by the way they said they got
inaccurate results like the people that
used the theranos devices said they got
inaccurate results dude
this test at walgreens
this is
this is the test that gets the most
accurate results
of all the tests in walgreens okay i
took a walgreens pregnancy test
and i got like a couple abortions i
didn't even need okay
i drew a lot of blood
for no reason
okay i would i would still take the
theranose blood test over a walgreens
pregnancy test
any fucking day
like even if the edison machine worked
and i got the correct diagnosis let's
say it did work right we're in walgreens
i got my diagnosis i have an issue i
need medical care i need a break you
still
walgreens would never have the
prescription ready
to be able to treat
your problem that was just diagnosed
like you would die waiting in line for
the prescription
like stop pretending walgreens wants any
of us to survive i want the bad blood
machines back because it'll give me
something to do other than the blood
pressure cuff machine while i wait for
my fucking prescription for six hours
which the reason your blood pressure is
so high is because i'm waiting because
they don't take your fucking insurance
right right that they said they would
take right two five-hour weight call
holds ago yeah it's just so funny to me
all the people that want this machine
now that they know that it gives
inaccurate results like you know who
really wants a thera-nose machine
tristan thompson
he's like how do i get one of those
inaccurate blood test results
for the paternity tests over here in
calabasas
by the way it's called the edison that
then he she named her little blood
machine the edison
you're not allowed
to just use the credibility of someone
else
for your thing to trick people into
thinking it's good like i can't just go
make a tv show and there's like colin
seinfeld
like i made this show called seinfeld
like oh it must be good like you can't
steal someone's name that didn't know
what the fuck they were doing
right and oh well this is so funny to me
because a couple people
they claimed that they got inaccurate
results you know what i mean which is
like it's a tough one because she wasn't
using her machines she was sending it
out to another lab right so that other
lab was technically giving inaccurate
results i know what this feels like as
someone that has like bought a lot of
food at the grocery store and pretend i
cooked it and then if someone like calls
you a bad cook you're like
yeah actually that was really hard for
her probably to keep her mouth shut
she's like actually this is fucking
question
yeah
that's really funny
it's just so funny i mean i just feel
like yes obviously it's like a scam but
i the machine was probably more accurate
than most human doctors because like
i've been i mean i don't know if it's
just like a girl thing but like when you
are a woman with any kind of pain in
your body
they're just like it's ibs
or it's your period right and i'm like
no i think it's like i might have like a
and they're like it's just ibs it's your
period i'm like i think i would know
right if i was shitting myself
and then bleeding on my explosive
diarrhea like i feel like i noticed like
i
i don't need you for that i would have
noticed that man i'm here because i'm
not shitting or bleeding
i need some help
staff
i haven't shit or bled in 15 years dude
i need your help
oh fuck
i don't know i guess i just like it's so
funny to me that
this woman
like she thought she was like
here's what was cool about it what was
cool about it she's like we're gonna
democratize healthcare like if you don't
if you don't have enough money to go to
a doctor and get your blood taken like
you can do this for free but then what
exactly exactly
also
it back to the bad results thing like
would she trick you into thinking you
had high cholesterol so you ate
healthier like oh man
i know exactly i don't want to think i
like have aids but like i don't mind if
you tell me i have high cholesterol and
i don't it could prevent you from having
the thing you got false diagnosed for
having correct
she's getting ahead of it
she gaslet you know thinking you haven't
so now you fix it also who's to say
that the results were false like what if
you got better by the time a real doctor
like if you had like a vitamin d
deficiency and you started taking
vitamin d and then by the time you got
your real doctor they're like you don't
have vitamin d deficiency theranost was
wrong it's like no i just sounds like
she needs a thank you
i guess it's just so wild to me that her
logic was i'm gonna help all these
people no money
get a diagnosis it's like well then
they don't have health
i have cancer great
now i just don't have any money and i
have cancer and now walgreens has your
information so you'll never get
insurance health insurance that's so
true she really so they're gonna she's
gonna tell the insurance company she's
selling your information so now everyone
knows you have cancer and no one will
give you
it's just like so funny to me that her
entire business
was based on the idea that people are
afraid of needles
which when you first hear it you're like
yeah i i was afraid of needles when i
was like five right it just it's
we live in a country that is fraught
with a heroin epidemic like no one's
afraid of needles in america okay people
in l.a get like seven booster shots a
day
between acupuncture appointments
like no one's afraid of needles she's
like you know what the military really
needs
they need to stop having to go ouch like
navy seals aren't afraid of needles
saying i'm pretty sure the navy seals
storming the caves of al-qaeda yeah
we're not afraid of a prick we weren't
afraid of a little needle like like he's
like she's like ah these pussies over in
afghanistan no i'm gonna help change
their lives
also why do we need the machine on the
battlefield that was like one of our big
selling points like we can get real time
test results on the machine like ma'am
the soldier's arm has been blown off we
don't need him to know he has high
cholesterol right now but oh wait can
you give me his arm
just give me the arm i just need one
drop
from the severed arm they're like
they're like all you need is is a prick
of blood from the finger oh can you just
give me his finger real quick and i'll
put it in the machine like these are
people at war
they don't give a fuck if they're iron
deficient dude they're not iron
deficient they're full of bullets
like no one needs this care do you know
what i'm saying it's just like it is so
funny we read the room the idea all
you're doing is giving the soldiers more
shit to carry
they're like now i have to carry around
this hp desk jet
like what the fuck in our backpack like
i like can we get some water please did
you make it camo colored
[Laughter]
it's also like you're in afghanistan
you have it
you have all of it
it's like yeah you don't need to test
the tongue you've got it scurvy leprosy
you're lying disease you've lied to it
you've been in afghanistan for 10 years
herpes like you've got er it says
melanoma stress
you have cancer
you have mercury poisoning like i just
i'll
like we don't even need the drop of
blood
like it's also like so many people got
got pissed because they went to
walgreens for their hiv tests
and they
first of all if you're going to
walgreens for hiv tests like you've got
it
look
like don't you like you've got it like
there's no
way around it and like they're like well
the results ended up being false
you thought they were true
which means
there's a chance you're still you're
gonna get it soon if you don't have it
now you will have it soon if if you got
your hiv results
from a fucking
lunch box
in next to the
blood pressure next to the blood
pressure cuff
from 1941 which by the way is is
literally just bombarding you with
radiation
if you go and it says you have hiv and
you're like
that tracks
like if i got an hiv result i'd be like
that sign can't be true
if you were like
yeah
that tracks coachella was pretty wild
this year like you you've got it
this i feel like
i feel like that's on you she get you on
you if she gave you a false like fatal
result uh-huh congratulations you just
got she gave you a brush with death
that's a gift she gave you a brush with
death she you all these people excuse me
i'm like can't hit my hair even if i
like my hair so fucking dead at this
point that it's just like a giant brillo
pad and uh if you
all these people they're like she told
me i had hiv i'm like you
yeah you seem healthier than anyone here
you had a brush with death you're
grateful second chances you got it yeah
you got if i would pay good money for
somebody to convince me i was gonna die
you were dying and then you like cut out
all the toxic people in your life you
get your priorities straight bungee jump
and then you die the a cool way
not because of a walgreens test suicide
you go out like a fucking
rock star
20 20. i'm gonna fuck you up
okay
any more you need to get off your chest
about liz holmes here because she's
about to go to prison dude i'm just
saying
as someone that pays taxes
i
i would like
i believe
a way to raise some money
for i don't know the debt or the debt
look i'm never gonna be able to run for
president because we all know there's a
photo out there of me with geisha makeup
on when i was 20 at halloween party so
look that ship is sailed um
if her and giz gillane gizl like share
to sell
start a podcast
oh
i will host it the money dollar download
the money from the podcast
goes to whatever
back to the
request diagnostics back to quest
diagnostics who now
their shit's about to
fucking get i'm sure their stock is in
the toilet because it's like no they
were the ones that gave the paper
results we use them so now they're
fucked
by the way do any blood
hey do anything we've always been using
quest right yeah i think so i think
there's only two companies so now we
know that no blood doesn't have ever
been accurate so the bar is low for any
other 19 year olds that want to drop out
of college that is so we all have aids
in the end on that
that is so funny okay i could talk about
this forever when benjamin comes back
and when our studio is up and cracking
i'm sure there would be more to say
about this i'm obsessed with this case
because i'm just obsessed with what
happens like
with
a 19 year old girl you know what i'm
saying like it is so funny that people
all these scientists
that were like we can't figure out how
to take blood from this 19 year old girl
she said she doesn't need college and
that she knows how to do it everyone's
like
well where is she
when you're 19 you lie that's the whole
thing you lied to to see how far you can
go
and then the smart people are supposed
to go no that's
okay that's how life works you have to
tell the truth and then some people will
figure out how to tell the truth other
people now there's that's why people are
in the metaverse because this this verse
sucks but like when i was 19
everything i said was a lie right i told
everyone i was a leap year kid
i just thought it made me more
interesting like
every time i was with a guy when i was
19 i was like i've never done this
before like you just you're 19 you're
trying to see when you get away
yeah i blame everyone else she's like i
didn't think i was gonna get this far
either what yeah
with you guys exactly yeah i thought she
was gonna win because her defense was
basically like
i didn't know what i was doing i was
like yeah yeah yeah why did you listen
why did all these like brilliant
businessmen give me all this money like
why didn't you like look into this right
right why did you let me lie for this
long right yeah that's so true like you
guys just started giving me money what
was i going to stop right be like you
know what guys i'm sorry i'm going to
give this all back
yes so funny to me
who's on the podcast
samurai samurail okay this interview is
awesome we did it before the holiday
because uh we had to redo the podcast
studio it's so fucking funny he's
hilarious i'm such a big fan um i know
that he's touring right now i'm also on
tour everything is up i am coming to las
vegas on the 15th and guess who is uh
featuring for me in las vegas oh a one
trailer trash tammy
vegas yeah chelsea lynn is going to open
in vegas at the encore at the win on
january 15th and then we're gonna be in
nashville
at the polk right and we're gonna have a
special guest in nashville that's at the
end of the month and then we go to
carolinas yeah and then touring until
april i'm shooting my special i will
announce the venue
soon but that's going to be i think at
the end of april or early may um boring
boring morning logistics um
thank you guys for asking me when the
podcast comes out all the time i'm so
glad that you care but
i hate saying the sentence but if you
subscribe
it'll just land in your lap like you
don't have to do anything subscribe and
then hit the bell and then
all the work is done i'm not going to
tell you what to do we just need one
like elizabeth holmes needs one drop of
blood we just need one click of the bell
okay and then everything else is done
everything everything else is bs so i'm
just kind of annoyed
that now my autobiography can't be
called one drop of blood
i love you guys when we come back next
week the studio is going to look even
better i love you and benton will be
feeling better enjoy samurai
[Music]
sam
morell yeah is here introduce yourself
oh you want me to introduce myself they
don't want to hear from me uh hi i'm sam
no i'm just stalling because i need to
find the document i wrote for you with
questions oh okay oh shit you prepare i
do
prepare i'm terrified of failure and
rejection and embarrassment well you
could also just be a preparer oh
no
yeah no i like to be prepared i don't
like just professional well here's the
reason i prepare so much because i never
want to ask a question that's already
been asked oh wow and i never want a
comedian especially to have to like
repeat a story that they've already told
on other podcasts because i believe that
the way people consume podcasts is
they'll watch your special on youtube
they'll watch your documentary on
youtube right or one of your specials on
youtube you have two now and then
they'll be like i love this guy and then
they'll see on the side there's a list
of other you know you on kfc radio you
want theo von you on whatever and then
they want to binge you so if you're but
if you you're corny if on everyone
you're telling the same story because
people ask the same questions fair
enough so i would love to you know be
the podcast that after someone is you
know overdosing on you and a bunch of
people were like dude this guy's amazing
let's see what else he's doing sure but
it's not like so how'd you get into
comedy it's like you've answered that on
the internet i know i'm just i'm not
used to doing podcasts i guess for so
many years you do the ones where they're
just like so what else and you're like
oh i gotta do this all right you invited
me here
like you invited me here the worst is
when i go to podcast and someone's like
how'd you get into comedy i'm like i've
answered this somewhere right and by and
or they'll go hard to be a woman in
comedy i'm like only because i've been
asked that question sure every podcast
yeah it's an annoying question like do
me a favor listen to one other thing
i've done also yeah so i like people the
people that ask is it hard to be a woman
in comedy haven't seen your place here
this is pretty good
um yeah it's hard to be a woman i get
lost in my house
that should be that should be your
answer it's so dangerous to live alone
oh my god i'm gonna start out with this
which i always start the podcast with
asking if the guest if we're friends
i mean
no i would say right i mean no not at
all we've met i think we've met once
we've met once at flappersburg bank
i think was a comedy but i just like to
establish this so that you don't feel
like you need to pretend for the next
couple hours no i mean you're
why are we pretending because sometimes
you go on a podcast and it's like oh
this is my good buddy whitney cummings
i'm like i've met you one time and now i
don't like being brought up on stage as
someone's friend
yeah what does that have to do with
anything friend who's funnier than you
to be clear what is what is that but
what does that have to do with anything
when someone's like this guy's a really
good friend of mine the clouds i love
when a comic's bombing and he's like
this guy's really good i'm like don't
fucking say that
i don't want to be a part of that let me
write my jokes yeah and also like we all
know comedians have no friends ever
let's be honest none
no real friends no no everything's a
podcast now everything's a positive we
should hang out and then they're like
they're like you see a little like uh
mike and you're like all right sure
here's what i'll say when i'm hanging
out in the comedy store uh hallway now
and if i'm talking like theo or spade or
you know whoever because everyone's got
podcasts or joey diaz will sort of be
talking to me like should we do this
tomorrow too
should we just hold this because this
we're having a really funny conversation
for just us like that weird thing
people used to say something funny and
it would just kind of like
go into the air somewhere and now
everyone's like it's got i mean it's
with stand up too if i have like a good
crowd riff i want to just put it out
there to promote a date and stay used to
you be i mean think about how many great
crowd moments are just gone just in
people's hippocampus and nowhere else
yeah it's in like 100 people's
hippocampus and like not in an algorithm
but yeah i think it is it's tricky
though because i i i'm torn about
filming my sets on the road all the time
because when i know a camera's rolling
i'm usually not as like free and fun
because i'm like what if i say off the
reservation or what if i say powwow or
what if i want to get used to tranny or
you know what i mean yeah but it's your
camera you don't have to you're not
going to like out yourself for saying
something everyone's got their phone i
don't know i think it just it makes me a
little more self-conscious or something
i do it now because like a lot of times
a comedian will like they'll get in
trouble for saying a joke
and then i'm like well the crowd is
laughing though yeah so i want to say
like well if i'm in trouble i want them
on camera laughing too
so if i'm going down they're going down
with me is my mindset for it yeah i
don't i don't know like i mean i've
talked about this before about comedians
being in trouble for jokes like i don't
really think it's happening the way we
think the way that comedians think it's
happening like we're sensitive by nature
like i always say like we can comedians
complain about sugar cookies like you
know what i mean complain about hot
pockets like there's nothing we won't
blow out of proportion that's what we do
right gaffigan famously loved hot
pockets well no i thought yes but i
thought he was complaining about them
when they're frozen in the middle maybe
yeah maybe it was part of it maybe i
froze in the middle
delicious but never would never complain
about it i get a starbucks egg sandwich
and i sometimes you'll get it like
frozen in the middle i'm just like ugh i
would say do you like that
i wouldn't if it was if it's a hop i
grew up on hot pockets that were lean
pockets that were frozen on the inside
we could never because if you microwave
them you can never get it
hot on the inside or if you toasted them
they never were even yeah it's not they
hadn't um perfected the product right it
was too thick
to be frozen and then heat it up without
some kind of dissonance between the
exterior and the interior like you would
burn your mouth but then you'd be able
to ice it right away yeah that's a good
point yeah so maybe they did
that's a great sales that's a great
sales technique if that's what it was
meant for this will burn your mouth but
instantly be iced yeah all in one
original icy hot mineralized yeah that's
what it is
it's like you know peanut butter and
jelly in one jar i hated that though
hated it but brian regan his bid on it
is so good that it was worth it any food
bit you know that brian regan or
gaffigan already did it yeah that's
right any yes yes totally i mean
remember gary goldman used to have this
so funny i was going to go to him now or
gary gomez that's what sugar cookies was
he used to have a 45-minute bid on sugar
cookies god damn yeah he would beat
something to death in like the best
possible way i'm like the grapefruit you
can't do a grapefruit bit because gary
goldman did the grapevine well yes and
did have you ever tried to eat an orange
within two days of brushing your teeth
i think that was gary goldman like he
did like 40 minutes on
eating an orange or drinking orange
juice after brushing your teeth he's a
great writer dude
he recommended me at the comedy cellar
he changed my life wow before the
pandemic he was on the show
and um made me realize i needed to go on
prozac forever grateful really and yeah
yeah because i because definitely
the only reason we can have a coaching
conversation in five minutes no i for me
i'll tell you about that in one second
because i just want to say this one gary
goldman thing when i went and saw him
perform at largo like it's very rare
i'll go see a comedian like run their
hour because either i'm doing stand up
like i took the night homework
yes it feels like homework or it's like
dude i'll see it right i'll see you next
week i'll see like i see comics
everywhere like i mean when comics but
don't you feel like usually when you
watch a special it's because it's like a
friend of yours and you have to yeah and
it's and it's that's not a fun way to
try to figure out why they got cancelled
yeah
let me just see it so i can defend you
yeah or but usually like bill burr like
you know sebastian like you know we're
lucky enough to be able to see
those get worked out so well you are
they're on the west coast so i usually
don't get to see those guys as much i
mean if i there was a summer where bill
burr was in new york filming uh
the judd apatown movie pete davidson so
i get to see him all the time and was
like mother's so fun to watch you know
but and so but goldman like i don't get
to see work out and he's so
like
reliant on silence and he's so surgical
and can talk about something he's not
meant to be in a club like he he should
be in theaters
from the beginning that guy should not
be doing those jokes in like reno yeah
it's not like and jalapenos like yeah
it's not but he did a because it's also
he the audience he requires from the
audience a training that they
that there's a couple beats after he
says what he's saying that they need to
process it sure because sometimes it
takes a minute so like he was taught and
he'll just walk you through it so that
you're kind of coming up the punchline
on your own and then he does his which
is way better so you get like two laughs
for the price of one so he's talking
about um mangoes and i'm like of course
he's talking about mangoes like the one
fruit he hasn't got to and he was like
mangoes
oh fuck and he's talking about cutting
mangoes he's like mangoes like they just
have such a low yield
like a low yield of fruit like
everyone's cut into a mango and been
like what the fuck man his word choice
is also perfect you're right it's like
that's it
you know he had a bit about uh ice cream
and how whenever you're eating it you
can never get it even so you just keep
going i was like that's the most
relatable thing when eating ice cream i
can't not think about that when i when i
eat ice cream now and it's such a
perfect um
sort of i don't know it's just his mind
is so to even occur to him to be annoyed
about it you know what i mean whereas
i'm eating ice cream and i'm like
fucking racism and inequality what are
we gonna do about the environment like
it wouldn't you're thinking that when
you're eating ice cream i'm saying you
know well you have like a list of things
that you're annoyed about in life i want
to meet an ice cream that's my that's my
quiet i'm not thinking to like protest
no well i mean because look i i think
when you're so fraught like i mean i'm a
woman and i've had eating disorders so
i'm eating ice cream and being like oh
what am i gonna exercise how many
calories does this have like i'm worried
about so many other things that does
have dairy i'm intolerant i'm not
supposed to eat this does that have
gluten like i'm am i gonna have a
migraine because it's too much sugar
like i have so many other things that
are going on but the fact that he's just
like you should be thinking about
lactose intolerance not racial
intolerance when you're eating ice cream
i think that's
like do you know what i mean like am i
eating this because my white privilege
does everyone get to have ice cream
whatever it's like so it just he makes
me realize my inner monologue when doing
mundane things because and how not the
best not present i am when i do things
because he's just like i'm gonna spend
some time thinking about you know this i
think his mind is never at peace i think
that's like a lot of great writers and
you're like oh my god you couldn't you
couldn't take a break during ice cream
you know so i mean nick griffin another
great joke writer in new york did a
million letterman sets a ton of late
nights that's used to a joke about ice
cream i know wearing ice cream jokes but
i i hear a joke when you're a kid you're
always at a party eating ice cream when
you're adult you're alone in the dark
you know in your car it's so
so dead-on though i have an ice cream
truck joke in my new hour yeah it's
about how like
people
uh now are so worried about you know
kids and getting on the internet and
getting misinformation on the internet
and it's i don't want to be a hack and
say it but it's like um like that's all
we got was misinformation before the
internet um my mom used to tell me that
when the ice cream truck played music
that meant it was out of ice cream oh
wow like the lies our parents told us to
like control us
wow but so let me ask you because okay
so watch the documentary i love that you
did like i love the positive coping
mechanisms of like the true artists i
feel like during the pandemic made
something did something like you just
basically started shooting a documentary
about
reopening new york and doing stand-up
yeah we were shut down for you know so
you guys know how it is out here it was
it was weird you have you have you
getting a routine of going to the clubs
you know with you it's the comedy store
with us on the east coast it was the
comedy cellar and we were used to going
there every night and and it becomes a
lifestyle and
it's part of your routine it's not just
a lifestyle i mean david tell it a line
in the dock where he said i i would just
walk down here and sit on the steps like
a homing pigeon and you're like that's
just so to me i was like oh fuck that's
since i was in high school i'd walk by
the cellar and just see a tell with a
cigarette on the stairs like that's he's
been there for like 30 years so
it's your it's part of how you are so
uh it's also something that's
interesting to me because there's so
much in the documentary that i don't
want you to repeat just in terms of what
happened and how everyone was kind of
you know you know trying to re-home
really and and and find their true north
during a time we all felt very
uh
hopeless but also just um
aimless i was like i don't know what to
do with myself like you know not saying
that maybe you're someone who seems like
you need to be busy like you need to
like you seem like you need you told me
before the podium like you don't take
vacations you're you're a hard worker
right vacations aren't relaxing to me
sure because they're expensive and i'm
just doing math the whole time on what
everything costs it's like a fruit plate
is 22. like i can't get over it so it's
like for a lot of people i like planning
vacations
when i'm it's fun for me to look forward
to something and to do the math and to
find the best deals but once i'm
actually there i'm like i'd kind of
rather just be with my dogs and in my
own bed and because we travel already
a vacation is like just getting on
another plane it's getting on another so
i feel getting on another tube of farts
so it's like so for me
i just like my main
takeaway with you and watching
the documentary and stuff is that we do
tend to over pathologize our superpowers
sometimes like it's not crazy that you
want to do stand-up every night it's not
sick it's not like you know just it's
like oh sam's gonna go do five spots
like like that's not crazy that doesn't
have to be
it's a positive addiction i believe very
strongly in positive addictions you're
not hurting anybody you're just making
yourself better and like honestly you
know louis c.k i want to say like for
14 years ago
i'm outside the improv and i was just a
baby comic and i was you know in la you
can do seven or eight spots a night you
just have to drive like i'd have to
drive which i do the comedy store then i
go to hermosa comedy i don't have to
learn to drive i'd have to then go to we
needed to talk about that too because
sam can't drive and i have some thoughts
but then you go to pasadena then you
come back you do the left factor then
you go back and the comedy store has
three rooms so you can do the hat trick
we call it and do all three sure sellers
exact same three rooms right when you go
around the corner now amazing and so
everyone's always like wouldn't you
still ambushes the word ambitious on a
woman is like shrill shirelle it means
you're not talented and all you do is
work hard
and it's supposed to be an insult and i
was always like good thank you like you
know i think i didn't realize so much of
when people were trying to hurt me in
the beginning they were accidentally
making me stronger and encouraging me
which must be such a bummer for all the
communi the male comedians or females
too they were assholes like do you
remember all of it do you hold on all of
it i don't hold on to it and honestly
i'm grateful for it i got a pretty rough
hazing and i get
a pretty crazy amount of negativity from
comedians men and women that just hate
me and and it took me a long time to
come to terms with it because as someone
that didn't have a like family i very
much felt the first time i walked into a
comedy club like oh
this is what family feels like you know
this is it like i feel at home i feel
like i can be myself i feel like i can
make dead baby jokes i've been people
like you know what i mean i feel like i
can say crazy shit or say nothing at all
or talk about
our i mean because comedians are some of
the smartest people on the planet and
the most curious and also some of the
dumbest people planet
so on one hand you know it's like like
you know rogan is in the hallway talking
about neuroscience and how crows hold
grudges for four years and then uh and
then someone's dick's out it's like the
best you know what i mean so
no no one's more fun to hang out and
then the person he's holding his dick
out to is going to hold a grudge for
four years just like a crow
[Laughter]
i mean
i'm just gonna tweet about it in four
years and so um so so i think that's
more why it hurt because i think when i
first uh
went in i was like oh my god this is the
first time i've ever felt like i i think
this is what a family is like but then
again families turn on each other and
families get weird and negative and
toxic
we misuse the word family all the time
like think about when you're on like an
airline they're like thanks for being a
part of the delta family and you're like
we're not i can't by the way i can't if
i have a weird thing in my family i
don't say anything
i'll fucking say it to an airline my
family will help me with my luggage and
give it back
exactly but it's it's all bullshit i
mean people just use the word it's like
bro or like i mean bro hey what's up
brother it's like someone you've met
twice i guess it was just the first time
like you know i was just very solitary
as a kid i didn't like have a lot of
friends because i worked during high
school um
to pay for school and stuff like that so
whatever it was i just felt like this
this this very this hallway that like
people want to write articles about for
how toxic it is was like a warm cocoon
for me sure you know whatever that means
it just perfectly
um
uh
gave me the exact cocktail of adrenaline
and dopamine and oxytocin that was like
oh this is it you know for me and
getting to work at night it was such a
relief to not have to like socialize
because i at the time had such bad
social anxiety i couldn't go to parties
and dinners it was so nice to be able to
go like parties feel like more work than
work that's what i'm saying so like for
us like dinner parties
small talk
you know i can't i can't that feels hard
for me vacations that feels like work a
lot of comics that you meet they just
don't suffer fools like they don't
suffer that small talk i mean and and
it's the best
and you cut through the bullshit so i
mean like
you know it's people you don't know well
but then you you know them so well so
a lot of comedians are open wounds
and there's a truth to that i guess
there's an honesty to just being like
here's why i'm fucked up you i mean you
can't be on stage talking about
something so deeply personal and then
get off and be like weather's weird yeah
yeah no i mean complete it's like yeah
it's like the morning after a weird
one-night stand you're like so anyway
you've already seen everything yeah
totally and then um there's i don't know
there was just an absence of shame that
i had never experienced as someone that
grew up you know with a very shame and
guilt-driven
thing and there was you know i grew up
around do you feel less shame now um
yes uh is is the main answer but also i
grew up around a lot of borderline
personality disorder where you walk on
egg shells and i have a hard time with
really sensitive people when you just
like hurt someone's feelings by accident
and you're just your intention and your
impact don't line up or whatever because
you've been through a lot i've always
just been very like it well no it's like
when you grow up around borderline
personality disorder these are people
that like if you advocate for yourself
if you need something if you're ready to
leave they take everything very
personally or as a personal criticism so
if you're like oh hey i'm gonna have to
head out and they're like you're leaving
already we just got like everything is a
thing sure and so was such a relief to
be around comedians who just weren't
sensitive right she was like hey asshole
what was this shirt and you can unless
you call out one of their jokes
there's that
but i guess for me like i was i i
okay
this is getting to to the o i believe
there's an over
pathologizing of how many sets you do
and
of yourself of like i'm addicted i've
got to do this thing like that
is a winner you know and louis ck
everyone used to make fun of me about it
everyone's going to do another set
winnie's going to do another set while
everyone's like i didn't drink i didn't
do drugs
also it's like there's a reason you do
so many sets as you're honing the
material i have to get funny like the
only way to get funnies on stage like i
already felt like i you know i was
brought up as like this next comedian is
very pretty uh and you're like why you
said that that's fucking awesome for
years it was always it was always about
stuff like that and it was always just
like i got haze in a way that i'm
grateful for like
i don't
is it because did you come up fast
because you were very young when you did
the roast is that because of that you
think well i was doing um i was the joan
rivers roast that i was right i wrote
for the rose first
so i submitted a packet for like like
two years in a row and they weren't
hiring anybody new and i basically my
manager at the time and i was 24. i was
on the settlement yeah i was instead of
a movie in england and i had written
rose jokes like a giant packet that
could work kind of for anyone it was
like older woman like sex symbol like i
just was working i was like i'm gonna do
this one day and i just constantly did
it and um it was
flavor flav
uh they were like they're not taking
anyone new and i wrote a packet
specifically for everyone that was on
the deus like like jokes and i was like
just send this to joel gallon the boss
just send this to him and have them send
this to the head writer and so um
there was one joke uh there was a joke
that he wanted to use and they were like
fuck like i was like i know and it was
um
about flavor flav and the joke was flave
you look like what magic johnson should
look like right now that's a great joke
and they were like fuck so we hate the
comics dude that instead of laughing i
process it through like i know it's a
good joke no
i know it's a good joke because you
didn't laugh and you were like a little
it's like a little jealous like well
like jokes where you say like but like a
stand-up joke is so we're just so used
to them that like if you it's a real
laugh when we're just talking but like
when it's like if that was a shitty joke
you'd be like
you're right you know what i'm saying
that's a really good joke uh yeah i love
a magic johnson joke too and this was
yeah this was a bit ago and it probably
sounds hacky now but no that's it i just
said it's a good joke why'd you do that
why did you just pull that back i just
commented but no it's not good anymore
you know why let me tell you why yeah
that was before twitter before you could
see so many jokes all the time you know
i feel like those sort of tight
one-liners that i love so much they're
really surgical tight ones that are all
my favorite things in the world but
so louis ck i'm outside i just really
want to make sure i finish the story so
people don't think uh his dick was
involved it was not um
it was not that's not where the story is
going um he uh i'm outside and he's
louis ck you know and i'm just a kid and
he was on stage and i was like leaving
and i was like oh hi everyone's around
him sure and um
i just say hi or something we had had
some thing in common i don't know and i
was like oh i know so-and-so or
something he's like oh cool and he's
like where are you going because he's
always looking to do more spots he was
living in new york and i was oh i'm
gonna head out to um
pasadena this place called the annex
which is attached to the um
ice house and and then i instantly
apologize i was like i know i just i'm
crazy and i just do like five spots a
night and i just it's just like this
weird tick and he just looked at me and
he was like
no that's what it takes yeah and i just
needed to hear that
because
comedians that didn't want to work that
hard were shaming me for it so that they
could feel better about their laziness
and the fact that they were just like
drinking and cheating
all right loser yeah you're like this no
this is what it takes i also i'm a big
fan of doing that many sets because when
you're a young comic you know and you're
doing those mics
uh i
jokes don't really do as well because
like you saw how i just responded to a
to a joke that you told me they just
that rhythm is almost predictable to
comics
even young comics so i feel like i
couldn't tweak jokes at open mics i
would have to do real crowds to figure
out jokes yeah and
now that we have real crowds i don't
take it for granted i mean i i love it
um i have a couple questions for you so
number one are there any like
new jokes or bits you're working on that
you're like it's not there yet like like
in terms of i don't believe in this like
we can't make jokes anymore that's not
true no no no you've been on the road
audi people they laugh at everything
people know the difference between a
joke and a statement although i do think
that though there is a different uh
there's a different ceiling for how how
high you can go how how fucked up a joke
you can make on the road as opposed to
like on social media where like
strangers come pop because there's
strangers that can pop they come they're
like tattles they're just like this you
can't do this i'm like you weren't even
here well also comedy is not meant to be
consumed at 2 p.m i know like don't do
comedy on twitter during the day that's
edgy i'll get comments on like late
night sets where people are like this
this was like kind of a bomb i'm like
why did a dead baby do no
oh no you're right oh my god i wasn't
getting attention for 10 seconds and i
had to still focus anyway
um no but you'll a joke won't hit and
they're like this is 5 p.m in burbank
like what do you expect it's also comedy
is also meant to be delivered
and performed in the dark after a couple
of drinks
saying it's not supposed to you're not
supposed to read it in your office in
between news headlines it's all context
you know you don't know who people
follow so if you're going to come out
swinging with a tweet and they follow
justin bieber and new york times and all
in the news and the weather and then
it's like
this cunt it's like if it's not we
assume people only follow comedians so
that the context is all rancher humor
you know edgy humor people like follow
their nephew and then their sister i
follow all comedians and then it's like
one porn star who just retweeted a tweet
of mine so i just followed her and and i
go over with taylor uh i don't i mean i
don't check twitter much but like the
thing is that i saw is uh
this one like years ago but i'm just
being like lined at the grocery store
and it should be like taking two cocks
and i'd be like yeah there's a time and
place for this and it's not the grocery
store you know what i mean
i mean you don't be scrolling i'm just
going through like comedian jokes then
you're like
a chick getting double-teamed it's a lot
we now take a break
from talking to the
incredibly chiseled and hilarious sam
morrell to talk about single-use plastic
single-use plastic is
so too thick
it's so 2000 and so is your phone
falling off your chair while you're
trying to construe a point
the thing is it's 2022
which is first of all news to me second
of all
it means that it's way past time to make
cleaning fun
okay beautiful and plastic free plastic
is gross
thank you blue land for having an idea
that is simple and beautiful you buy the
bottle once you refill it forever no
more plastic waste the only thing you
really need to discard is your outdated
idea that quote eco-friendly products
are more expensive and less effective
blue lands stunning
high quality forever bottle start at
just 10
when you buy a kit and are meant to be
reused
forever
with money saving refill tablets that
start at just two dollars right now you
can get 20 percent off your first order
when you go to blueland.com
whitney that's 20 off your first order
of any blue land product at blueland.com
blueland.com
whitney and i'm gonna need blue land
cleaner to clean up all the spit i just
spat all over myself during this read i
don't know why i'm so spitty today
you know when i'm not running my mouth
you know what is happening to my mouth
i'm
jamming food into it when i'm not
talking which is rare i'm eating and
when i'm eating it is very rare that
it's not the thing that i want to be in
my mouth i'm at a point in my life where
nothing goes into my mouth unless i want
it to
read into that as deeply as you would
like to because that's where i'm going
okay
you need to get what you want to eat
right now
and right to your door with doordash
with over 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood go to's or
choose from your favorite national
restaurants you can get popeyes chipotle
cheesecake factory me and benton's
personal favorite ordering is easy and
your items will be left safely outside
your door when you choose contactless
delivery and drop off it's very
simple it's like the it's like a
one-night stand with food for a limited
time our listeners can get 25 percent
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app enter code gfy
that stands for good for you that's what
this podcast is called that's 25 off
that's a lot of money 25 off
i thought i read that wrong and i
normally do but i didn't this time 25
off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the door
dash app in the app store and enter code
g
f y don't forget that's code g f y for
25 off your first order with door dash
subject to change terms may apply on
that note back to the great sam morel oh
i want to ask you a little bit number
one you went to school in new orleans
for a year and a half how was that
it wasn't great honestly i i mean it was
i saw a therapist who my parents sent me
to therapy to deal with stuff and uh
it was right when katrina hit it i am
gonna make you tell this story what is
this the therapist that hit you over the
head
in a bar no that was a
no wait oh that was in new orleans that
was in vermont that was another time
yeah that is true yeah yeah true story
so in vermont what happened was we'll go
back to the new orleans stuff but in
vermont what happened was um
i was doing a club vermont comedy club
i'm with a friend of mine carmen lagala
who's uh who's open for me she's from
vermont she's like we should go to this
bar um across the street i'm like oh
cool so it's like me carmen two of her
friends who are uh you know local
comedians and uh
this guy just walks over to me and he
was like he's drunk and he was just like
you know just kind of
had a bad vibe about him now he walked
over to me and was like kind of he was
like university of vermont and i was
just like uh no and he goes a master's
degree and i said uh you're getting
colder is what i said and uh
then he just said i'm gonna beat the
shit out of all of you and we just kind
of looked at each other and i'm like
this guy's nuts i just turned my big
mistake was turning around he took a
pint glass full of beer and just smash
it over my head so his hand was bloody
too
was what i found out later did it break
right away yeah yeah i was saved by my i
had long hair i had a ju-fro and it
smashed and it was like an air bag it
did save me a little bit that's like my
tits when i broke my shoulder and i hit
the ground they said it stopped me from
getting a concussion it's weird right i
mean but it did help the the cops even
were like when they showed up and of
course my mom found out because i posted
an instagram story about it trying to be
fun my mom's like what the fuck happened
dude scalps bleed like all hell i was
cut up and like my neck and stuff but it
was like probably a mild concussion it
wasn't that bad and then uh the cop he
ran out and just kind of he like stared
us down and i'm just like what it's
vermont i'm like assuming he has a gun
you know so i'm like what the hell so i
he runs out and he's like not getting
far they call the cops and what i
actually i say this and i do a joke
about where i actually did say you all
heard him call me ju-face before he did
it
and you know uh some some of the bars
like i didn't hear that and i was like i
was joking but uh
it's a joke i was trying to be funny
because i could tell people were like
nervous i was they thought it was like
badly hurt i was like i'm all right i
was just more shocked than
uh hurt but then
um
he's running off the cops get him and
the cops talk to me and
uh we find out later like you know
there's a
victim's advocate which i hate that word
uh victim's advocate she called me and
she was like so we're just going through
it he's a therapist
uh and i'm like well he's probably not a
very good one but like what happened
here's what happened so she broke down
the whole story for me he
he was going through a bad divorce so he
got blackout drunk and he just wanted is
that classic shit like he wanted someone
to beat the shit out of him i think
that's why he started shit with me he
wanted someone so he went for the cops
gun hoping to get shot by the cop
but how do you know that's what he was
trying to do because that's what she was
breaking down uh the the victim advocate
she was like this is what we think he
also might just be an asshole he might
be but i mean it was a felony so he did
i think he like you're like what do you
want to do do you want to like fly out
here i'm like so i gotta fly back to
vermont yeah get involved yeah like no i
don't want to deal with this but they
but they said he's trying to get into
this mess i'm like i want to talk to his
clients i want to talk to his patients
this is insanity well yeah it's also
like a physical therapist
no he was a mental therapist there's a
lot of crazy therapists out there and i
feel like there's this people don't
think they're just good because there's
a lot of bad doctors
with a god complex that's a lot of
people that want to focus on rescuing
other people so they don't have to look
at their own stuff it's a lot of
unrecovered codependence it's a lot of
it's like the same way a lot of
anesthesiologists have drug problems you
know it's a lot of uh
everyone thinks it's robin williams and
good will hunting it's not your fault
but it's like no they're fucking
lunatics out this guy guy had just
attacked me for no reason and uh
i mean by the way this is i'm obsessed
with crazy therapist stories uh we have
a famous story on our team uh emily she
went to a therapist on halloween it was
like the first available halloween and
he showed up in a cat costume with
whiskers she has a picture oh with
whispers on his face and a bushy tail
it was like how can i help you
i want to commit suicide now i just want
to kill you i guess i don't know
will you text me that photo i cannot get
enough of it um yeah and also i think a
lot of therapists because it's something
i feel like as as we're comics and we
talk about therapy so much i always have
to say like like free therapy is 12 step
programs like alan on aca that's what
i've been in forever most people can't
afford therapy so yeah i always like to
say like let's not get into this like
elitist like therapy hole sure um and
you can pop it there's a lot of slide
and scale therapists out there as well
it was like group therapy stuff because
a lot of times sitting down and talking
about yourself is the last thing you
need because you're going to re-embed an
old story or a trauma
and the best thing you do is not talk
about it or there's a lot of therapies
that enable and make you worse if
they're not giving you active tools or
suggesting emdr for real trauma or
suggesting some kind of like work
outside they're probably just you know
they want you to stay sick or they're
just fucking with your head or further
embedding your victim mentality sure
like my therapist i you know i i'll go
once a month then sometimes twice a week
and like depending kind of as needed but
she said to me when we set first out and
she's like my goal is that i don't see
you forever i don't i don't have time to
do that there's too many people i never
believed them well she's she's no i went
in when i was in a very um
addictive romantic relationship you know
i was diagnosed as a love addict um i'm
like the dorky addict who couldn't like
do something cool like cocaine or heroin
and um and she was like i love attic at
least you get material you get breakup
jokes that's true i know my second
special um and so uh she
i was like and then he did this and then
he did this and then when you're so
obsessed with somebody and you're just
you know and she was like you can't talk
about him for 30 days
to nobody because basically you're it
takes 30 days to break a habit right so
like when i would apologize all the time
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry you know
that thing where women just have to like
apologize like a tick she's like you
can't you can't apologize um unless
you've done something
wrong uh for 30 days and then i'd have
to stop every time and i like snap
myself with a band to train my brain to
stop doing it and that's what works so
she gives you actual tools
because if you go to a trainer once a
week
for your body and just talk about what
you want to do that's not going to get
you in shape same thing with mental
you know and also how many times a week
do you have to go for mental health it
depends it's like around the holidays i
up it a little bit because i have lots
of
ptsd around holidays because that's when
fam my family would congregate and
that's when it was like
i felt bad you ever just laugh right
before someone says something really
horrible yes you're like let me just
i am so glad we're on the same page i
i'm gonna ask you about therapy because
um
i
i because i'm asking you about the like
working on bits not because i'm trying
to like make you do bits but i feel like
i do bits and therapy a lot
how does that go
he kind of just like just get it out is
this the comedian therapist yeah alan
okay i love allen yeah he's helping me
he's a therapist in new york that just
sees comedians no he's uh he sees other
people too but he sees a lot of
comedians gary goldman i think was my
wreck for the comedy seller and allen
gary's gary's done a lot for me uh no he
uh
he's great no i'll i'll just have to get
sometimes the only comedian that he can
like talk to without hunching over
that's why he likes you so much well i
remember the fucked up thing is i
remember my friend phil hanley was in
therapy before me and i heard him get a
big laugh and that's so unhealthy to
hear before you go into therapist cause
your first thought is like i gotta bring
it this week now i gotta i gotta bring
the heat you know that is so funny but
it's like you know
you want to not do that i mean i grew up
on dr katz like that got me in a stand
up remember that show yes of course
because it was like he was a therapist
who only saw comedians
and it was you know louis you think
no it's jonathan katz i know but hugh
fink i think ran it doctor it was called
doctor but it was like uh
you know dave attell was on it ray
romano uh mitch hedberg like everyone
you could think of
and uh it's great it's but i thought of
and then you're a silver man yeah she
was great on that she's a secretary
h sean benjamin there's a son yes wow
dom herrera domino ron lynch wow this is
crazy kindler wanda sykes
yeah is that is that on netflix now
dude anything that was on comedy central
is impossible to find
you have to like
download a plug-in player every time and
then answer a riddle
yeah you just have to you have to take a
blood test i mean it's like you go to
their website and i'm just like i feel
viruses like i pop up ads i'm
downloading malware
tests
like i don't understand what is
happening um but um
i do you have to get the vaccine
to get a chip in your arm um but i
there's a couple i just want to talk
through this with you because i do feel
like
you know
you we have a very
we have a the same philosophy in terms
of what a comedian's job is you know
which is not to be a hero it's not to be
your kid's idol anytime a comic is going
up there and trying to say the right
thing it's like i got good at this
talking to strangers in bars like you
got to remember
your origin in this like we're not
fucking
preachers or philosophers you know we're
entertainers if something is
philosophical great if something it's
gonna be funny though
yes and you know but the point is like
we're not your hero i hate when comics
go up in like in manhattan and they're
like i think the gays should be allowed
to get married and you're like ooh bold
take you all you okay you also cheat on
your what you are married you are
allowed to and and you cheated on your
wife like you're not a lord it's like
it's like when like a senator is like
very is all holier than thou and then
you're like oh you fuck little boys but
that's by the way that's it that's why
like any republican that's like
uh i don't believe in gay marriage
you're the one that fucking taps your
foot in the airport and fuck someone
through a hole you know what i'm saying
sure so to me anyone who's too outwardly
self-righteous or pious that's always
like what are you hiding anyone who's
old yeah when i see a dude in a
sweatshirt that says like feminist i'm
like uh oh
buddy yeah get you and yeah i feel like
um
to me when someone's outwardly i'm a
piece of shit i'm like i got you i trust
you i totally trust you because it's
like what we do in 12-step programs
which is like you say well you're
setting the bar low but you're also just
saying look it's i think it's all so
humbling but they're not going to
surprise you if the bar is down here but
if someone's kind of like i'm this great
person you're like where where the
skeletons dude yeah it's always a little
bit fishy when someone like goes out of
their way to show you how good of a
person they are because it's like people
that don't abuse women don't like go out
of their way to like make a statement
like a press conference you know yeah
but here's what i'll say it's like
comedians i think right now i think they
were
like some of them were hoodwinked into
thinking that you know maybe it was
because the pandemic and they weren't
getting attention and whatever that
their authorities on politics or morals
or how you should vote it's like you're
an authority on alcoholism depression
adultery a lot of things you know what
like how to get from the seller to
danger fields in 10 minutes like
stay in your lane like you can't
do a special about how you're like this
drug addict drunk and then be like but
you need to listen to me when it comes
to political issues it's like
what are you doing
yeah it is
it's weird because i do think like jon
stewart was so good at what he did that
it kind of became the norm for
communities to be like well that's what
i'll do and it's kind of like what well
he made it look easy you know it's like
you had a team of emmy-winning writers
and that's all he did you know what i'm
saying yeah but how many shows were just
carbon copies of what john stewart did
afterwards and just you're like well
this isn't working but what worked which
is this is i think what is so uh
backwards about hollywood is like i've
told this story before i'm sure emily
cuts it out every time but
that after bridesmaids happened right it
was this huge movie that uh was you know
five women in the cast and they're
raunchy and they're shading in wedding
dresses and melissa mccarthy's genius
and it's huge makes a billion dollars so
then right after that
you know studios will call me and and
and they go hey we want the next
bridesmaids we want the next bridesmaids
oh you want the next obvious like yeah
everyone wants the next hit but then
they go we want another show where it's
like you know a movie where it's five
women and maybe it's like the
bachelorette and it's like no no don't
replicate the movie replicate the fact
that it was an original idea exactly you
know what i'm saying but that's not how
they think they only everything's a
sequel everything's dollar signs
everything's a remake yeah and it never
like it's so funny you know they do like
i know you did last summer as a tv show
now you're like now we're we making bad
shit
that's where we're at it's like
everything is a remake i know the box
office you did 15 summers ago
it's it is horrible and i think that
that is more a product of the fact that
nostalgia is so sure right people are so
eager for something nostalgic i also
think that the people that have money
now
grew up on those things like if there
was on my so-called life reboot i would
like quit my job to watch it it was
making back to school with dandruff i'm
like why are you fucking with the
classic like that
yeah and i ended up not doing it i think
roseanne did very well and i think saved
by the bell has done very well you know
yeah the on the peacock yeah the comedy
ones actually do pretty well the drama
one's not as much because remember they
remade melrose place they rebate 90210
dallas dynasty like those have not been
those have not done well but it's also
there's something to be said for like
you know
yeah unless it's rami or unless it's
something so rami is so unique it's just
like there's i mean that's why you can't
do something unique just just
you know keep the money going to the
state of the writer from 20 years ago
like i'm you know what i mean some widow
is getting that money reboot money and
like whatever
but let me ask you oh
what i'm saying about john stewart is
don't
don't go i'm gonna do a political show
go i'm gonna do a show that showcases my
strengths that's about my personal
obsession so if you were gonna do one
you know it either would be like you
know like a sports show
and you'd be brilliant at it and you
would be the jon stewart of that there
are you know there's not really a
politics show or sports show no but it's
just it's a bummer you're scrolling
through whatever streamer and it's just
remake remake i mean you're like holy
shit they're making a fifth scream like
the first one is great the first one's
awesome but usually it's just it's a
money grab and then i think on the third
one they just were like they didn't even
have the same screenwriter and you're
like well this is like why it was good
yeah because it was that guy was a funny
writer yeah but most movies aren't good
and that's okay i don't think everyone
when they sit down wants to watch a good
movie i think i think i think some
people just want to check out and watch
something mediocre that doesn't make
them think too hard that doesn't make
them sweat that they can sort of you
know breastfeed their kid and make
dinner and it's just kind of like it's
just on there's something soothing about
a bad movie a cheesy shitty movie where
you're like i know this is bad i don't
have to engage and go is this good is
this brilliant is my favorite movie this
is like sideways this was like it's like
there's something nice to just be like
this sucks
it's just a fun watch it's low pressure
yeah i don't have to yeah it's on in the
background i can pop in i can pop out
i'm not like because good movies are
like glued to the screen and you feel
guilty sometimes picking those if it's
just on tv you're like go ahead and pick
this it's just there but yes if you if
you select it on it on an app it does
feel kind of weird sometimes yeah it's
just sort of like there's you want it to
be an accident yes totally like i guess
this is on yeah like that's why i love
like just lifetime movies and stuff like
that because it's like it's just
background noise
[Music]
if you don't watch the wendy williams
lifetime movie you do not you hate
yourself
it's that good you hate is it
it's her life story it's her life story
so there's a documentary that's on hulu
and then the life or the lifetime it was
a documentary her life is nuts and she's
larger than life she's very um
what's the word um
opulent person
in emotionally and otherwise you know
very extreme very dramatic and it is
very dramatic in the best way
it's in you know it's like emotional
porn emotional hardcore porn
interesting it's it's it's and it's you
know like you were talking about um
on a podcast about like the shows that
you watch and you know the godfather and
mad men and all these shows which my
only thought you're like i love bad men
i love the sopranos what are your
favorite shows i mean that's it
basically are there any shows you like
where women are equals
i am so sorry to interrupt again i'm
interrupting myself
this
sorry i know
sam is the funniest but i just want to
talk to you guys real quick about our
next partner um it's athletic greens you
know athletic greens
if you're not taking athletic greens at
this point i truly think you're a
psychopath okay with one delicious scoop
of athletic greens you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens
to help you start your day right it's
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free
athletic greens is a small micro habit
with big benefits it's the thing that
you can do every single day to take
great care of yourself it costs you less
than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit right
now it's time to reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition especially heading into
the flu and cold season it's just one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it what's what is your problem
no no need for supplements and a million
pills and a bunch of things pills make
me gag by the way i thank god for
athletic greens because i'll take a pill
i'm like
thank god for athletic greens to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
that's a lot
all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com
whitney
again that's athletic athleticgreens.com
whitney to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
make your friends jealous
speaking of friends
jealous friends good friends
bad friends
best fiends gosh
honestly i'm sitting here alone in a
podcast studio no one's here everyone's
got coven
um and i am
so
freaking grateful
for best fiends i'm like honestly i
i i shudder i shudder the thought of
what i would be doing
sitting home alone with everybody gone
without best fiends because best fiends
is like it's
you know ben and i played all the time
when we're traveling we play
we're like sitting at the game we're on
the plane you know instead of doing
something self-destructive like just
compulsively online shopping because i'm
on tour i've been playing so much lately
i am on level 101
no big whoop
and if you're confused about what best
fiends is because you're a weirdo uh
that lives in a bunker best fiends is
the perfect puzzle game to lose yourself
in because you're having so much fun the
game features tons of cute characters
that help you solve thousands of fun
puzzles the more you play the more
characters you collect and the more you
win the more challenges you face
download best fiends free today on the
app store or google play that's best
friends without the r best fiends now
back to sam morelle and joy do you like
any shows where women aren't crying
30 rocks
[Laughter]
but it's just funny to me because like
what a guy now is like dude i'm obsessed
with mad man it's like no you
want to live in that area no i love the
writing i think the writing is great
everyone's like i just feel like another
hmm
what's it what's a new show that's that
you like did you like narcos fleabag was
great fleabag's amazing that's women
again woman crying
woman oh no woman had getting anally
fucked in the first scene no i'm totally
joking you would love me
i don't think i would but there is
something interesting i think that's
true i want it to be subtle abuse i
don't want to be able to tell
psychological abuse and yeah yeah i'm
really picky about what i watch because
i just am trying to be i'm so
um sensitive like when i
i take it on like i get you wear it i
get like lost in it i get obsessed i get
like there's the show coming what's your
favorite shows let me tell you real
quick just christina ricci's coming on
um uh or was just on whatever however
this airs and um
there's a show called yellow jackets it
is about a soccer team in the 90s who
gets in a plane crash and on an uh like
the middle of the woods in uh like upper
canada and it's lord of the flies with
girls
it is
bananas dude
and they all like turn on each other and
start eating each other it's fucking
amazing so it's just that's what that's
the norm now it's like squid game right
just people murdering high school for
girls yeah um but
so i i i was riveted i mean like i can
you know as someone that i think still
has a little bit of a
not guilt but like an embarrassment or a
frustration of
the last couple shows that i was doing
like didn't happen there's a little bit
of a like
well
i could have written that or i could
have done that with comedy it's hard to
watch comedy sure because i'm like i
auditioned for that you know you still
have in the back your brain that
jealousy or that
embarrassment or that kind of like they
should have done it this way and oh
that's a you know that's like
so-and-so's joke like every now and then
you'll see a joke in a show or you're
like
it reminds you of another joke and so
many shows now that everyone loves her
about female comedians i can't watch
anything
i can't well hannah is on um
yeah true and she's a jew a lot of them
are like jews
but played by non-jews
well there's that sarah silverman was
very clear on that um i mean catherine
hahn is so brilliant i love her but yeah
i think she's playing joan rivers i'm
not that fun to watch tv and movies with
because i'm like i'm the like you
analyze everything well i'm just like
focused on the thing that is not at all
the selling point yeah you know what i
mean sure like
narcos there was a german shepherd in it
and i was just like that dog has hip
dysplasia i couldn't watch that either
like i would the dog loves that show but
the dog had hip dysplasia and so i was
like on the set are they giving the dog
these anti-inflammatories that need well
then they shot the dog and i was like
okay well we're done here that was
the whole american side of that story i
was like this is like over the top
comical i couldn't it didn't feel real
to me and then the drug side was very
good but i yeah you know you can visit
his house in uh pablo's yes columbia my
friend dory went right you can go on
like a tour and there's like bullet
holes that like it's apparently pretty
amazing entry we should we'll plan a
trip yeah that's my kind of vacation
let's go see where a bunch of people got
sprayed with bullets columbia's supposed
to be beautiful yeah so this is a i'm
obsessed with premises not words i'm not
afraid of words or saying words or you
know just this i think that the more you
know comedians it's our job to play in
the taboo and say things that are taboos
so the more things that are taboo the
funnier we get so the more words that
are off the better things go like i'm
like comedians stop complaining about
cancer culture it's the best thing that
could ever happen to us i mean not if
you like
rape i also don't yeah yeah i think like
cancel culture in regard to joke every
comedian is like whatever we're talking
about like raping someone you're like
yeah they should be cancer that's not
cancelled that's just illegal that's
just that people are allowed to respond
to something horrific you didn't say
indian instead of native american that's
not what that was you know i i'm yeah i
don't think
i don't think many people are worried
about that i don't know i think you're
the person to run this by there's a
premise that i'm it's weird that i'm not
able i don't the jokes aren't there yet
sure but it's something i'm scared of
because i feel like
there was this conversation about like
toxic masculinity and like i also don't
want to bash men or be negative towards
men but something i'm noticing is
someone that's in therapy who does not
do what i'm about to say
um i find it hilarious that so many
older men now all men but men like in
their late 30s and 40s are going to
therapy probably largely because of
people like you that talk about it and
like i don't think it's because of me no
not but i'm just saying like i think
it's usually someone in their life
that's like you need to go to therapy no
it's but someone who's cool
and it's like i went to therapy it
helped me i don't know like it makes it
less of a you're a pussy i think woody
allen popularizes my analyst all this i
think it was that type of thing i think
woody allen was the worst advertisement
for therapy ever because he just got
worse and worse and crazier and crazier
every year he never got better yeah well
he's probably carrying a lot of stuff
around
i am i know he doesn't strike me as the
type of person who's honest in therapy
you don't know he's just so
self-indulgent and never ever we
this is one thing new yorkers i always i
i don't like woody allen i don't think
he's funny uh i mean i think his movies
are great i don't think he's a good
person do that good really
bullets over broadway yes it's fine
that's a good movie if you love new york
and grew up in like i understand the
porn of the city i just i'm not going to
pretend like his movies make me laugh
they just don't know no it's not for
danny hall was originally a horror movie
that he had to recut because it was so
bad it was called anadonia right changed
it and as annie hall is his his genius
is casting
right his genius is casting diane keaton
here's my problem with diane keaton
everyone's like annie hall anyhow it's
like she's an idiot
she's an idiot
ninny in the movie who's like hey don't
make it i had a lot of that like why
can't you speak like get it out you're
40.
i don't buy that she was like so nervous
around woody after playing tennis with
him i don't buy that also
if a man over 40 complains i'm you make
me sick
why are you complaining so much pull it
you're scared of a lobster like i k it's
so
it's so gross you're like a different
type of man i just i don't buy
you know i don't buy it no no do you
ever hear wayne fetterman's joke where
he goes uh what what are you having uh
my hero all these years and still
married to the same daughter
oh
so funny that's a great joke also that
was weird
yeah that's my first memory i met him on
the street when i was like six and i
knew him from the tabloids
i i'm like i was a six-year-old who knew
woody allen from the tabloids kathy
griffin
has a story i she she stopped by do you
know this story because she told it i
think she told it in one of her specials
woody allen would not speak to her she
was like i don't this was before the
head this was before like all the
controversy with kathy
if you're a comic and you're a dinner
like for me
when comics go to when i'm in a fancy
thing oh my god i'd be thrilled to see a
comic yeah like i don't even care if you
we don't like it you don't like me or we
haven't gotten along like comedian thank
god yeah yeah like thank god and we're
just going to hide in the corner and
make fun of everybody for sure so
for a comedian tonight to not even want
to talk to kathy at all it's just weird
she was like so what's your favorite
band what's your favorite movie like was
just trying to like woody okay he must
be a narcissist just ask him about
himself he'll want to talk about himself
he he finally
answered she was like well what's your
favorite tv show his real answer i don't
read i bet he said he i mean i don't
watch i don't watch movies i don't have
time what do you think his favorite
movie was
i bet it was like i'm sorry favorite tv
show
woody allen i bet it's something is it
is it all give me a hand is it old or is
it
old well it's young and old
i have no idea what is it
hannah montana woody allen is what he
said
dead serious that's fucking bad
wild that is not good that was like sick
five years is that who is that uh what's
her name miley cyrus
jesus that's like was he trying to be
funny no
that's not you know what i'm saying
like like it's just there's no way to
process it it's too wild
shit
bummer that's a bomber that's something
that made me sad that's a major bummer
no he's something he's someone that i've
had to kind of make peace with is a
terrible person i mean that's it's tough
i mean uh i just like why is he putting
all these beautiful women in cargo
shorts from the gap like why is emma
stone
wearing a white tank top under an olive
green tank is that him or is that a cop
the way he trusts his women no i mean he
makes every decision really the way that
he like
i don't know it's just
i don't like that all the women in his
movies are obsessed crazy psycho that's
the way he sees women like lucy punch's
character um
i didn't notice in blue jasmine the way
she spoke to her kid i was like that's
not how a mom talks to him he just hates
women yeah i wanna think he knows how a
parent talks to a kid the one that what
was the christina richie one with um
jason baby jay said she's like this
crazy side like every woman is a nut
case
as someone who is a nut case i take
homage at this that's not how you write
a nutcase that's crazier
the women he writes should need to be in
a conservatorship like they're a danger
to themselves sure the way that they
behave you're like what is happening
that was that was brittany right this is
yeah this is how you see women it's so
dark but let me um
i'm just curious if there's any premises
that you're like
kind of dancing around and you're like i
haven't like
a bit you mean yes i'm working i'm
working on one about how men are going
into therapy in their late 30s and 40s
and they've decided like like scumbags
and they come out and they're like
i know what happened
the reason i struggle with intimacy in
relationships is my dad didn't love me
like they got some information from
their therapist or some feedback that
was like this is why you do this it's
you're just a victim you're just a
puppet of the marionette doll operator
that is your childhood damage and
they'll be like and because i had an ex
recently go and that this is why i
cheated on you as because
you know my dad didn't love me i'm like
that's the only reason why
like wasn't because she was hot
wasn't cause you could like you're most
disappointed it was only you saw this
gorgeous
you know i think she was like a stripper
and and you were like
daddy dad didn't throw me that baseball
i gotta fuck that thing like are you
sure that in using it as
a way to just
completely remove responsibility from
their own choices
like i don't have the exact thing down
yet but there's something really funny
about that there's something funny about
about
about you blaming your dad for your free
will you're 40. you're yeah at a certain
point your dad's off the hook
yeah i mean yeah you're dead your dad
never loved you so you fucked the
stripper like i feel like that's a plus
beat is not i don't think you've gotta
you've got a good therapist
he's very supportive
well now everyone will go to therapy
yeah there's a line around the block for
that therapist yeah but there's just
it's something funny to me about like a
45 year old guy being like
this is because is he really sick
because my dad didn't love me well it
was like something of like my dad was
gone a lot and i saw him disrespect my
mom so i did the same pattern i'm like i
don't you didn't see him go to a strip
club oh so here's my issue with that too
is like a lot of people see that and
they're like well i'll never do that
you know you just you guys
i mean it's like kind of like when my
dad's an alcoholic so i'm an alcoholic
i'm like yeah but a lot of people saw
their dad being an alcoholic and was
like i'm never touching booze but then
i'm confused because she he was like she
it's like okay
if we're going to go down this logic if
i'm going to believe you on this
my dad was gone a lot and he
disrespected my mom
and like ignored her and was rude to her
then shouldn't you have ignored him been
rude to the stripper and been gone but
you're the mom in this situation right
that and that's his mindset now you're
just calling me old now i need to go
back in
so it's like it's just a little like i
just like that someone when they go into
therapy for the first time because your
dad and they think they have some big
way to complete because true therapy is
that was your responsibility you own
apology you're your own person you're
not your story like good this is why
this all the pain happened but
you're a grown adult now and sure you
know he's 40. he i don't i'm just saying
i'm just making up vague numbers i think
he's older than that now but i love the
idea of when people come out of therapy
and they're like
we cracked it i know what's wrong yeah i
did nothing wrong yeah and my dad didn't
play football with me it's it's like
they act like they solved the mystery
but and they the way they think it's
going to go over yeah is what's funny he
was expecting a big hug for that mic
drop
mic drop yeah they expect you like
like what how did you think this was
gonna go
yeah there's something interesting about
i just love a therapist giving you like
that he thinks that's gonna be the out
or that was his takeaway yeah like i'd
love to have seen the exchange
and then
the person's takeaway you know what i'm
seeing when someone's like yeah my
therapist said that you just need to
stop being so aggressive and you're like
i feel like you
contorted that to benefit yourself
he made himself the victim
when you're the victim of this situation
yeah right yeah or not i mean every time
you well if you're being cheated on i'd
say that
i got jokes out of it made me stronger
that's that's not a healthy you can't
say that too that's not what you're
dating i'm just making you stronger yeah
i was trying to give you material
that's why i did that in vegas you're
welcome you have a new closer
yeah i'm just
your shirt smells like perfume you're
welcome you are welcome now you have an
ig story
no that's uh he's making himself the
victim when
i mean that's the problem with therapy
for some people is that they don't they
don't take a real look at themselves
like they're they're not looking at
they're looking at
to blame well they're not looking at
their impact right i mean he's he's
looking at
how he's hurt from that situation rather
than i mean it's great if you want to
break patterns but also like
if you cheat on someone you got to talk
about that yeah and like shit like
yeah i heard a person you can't yeah
yeah yeah
and let me is there anything that you're
working on in therapy specifically right
now
or like what is a habit you want to
break habit i want to have to be big
psychologist i think empathy i think i
lack empathy in some ways and like i'm
trying
would you say it's for
because there's a difference between a
lack of empathy
and
getting bored easily and a lot of it's
getting bored easily i i i very bad add
i disconnect i i yeah but a lot of
problems are not yours to solve either
so a lot of times people over correct
the other way and they're so codependent
that they they solve problems that
aren't theirs they pity people that are
adults that they don't need to pity yeah
like you know some you don't need to
rescue anyone you don't need to take on
everyone's feelings like i have the
opposite my thing is i have too much
empathy and i'm trying to clean up
everybody's messes all the time and i'm
trying to like like get in everybody's
lives and here's the and here's how
we'll fix it and we'll do this and then
i'm in all these toxic i'm raising
adults yeah you know what i'm saying and
not giving them the dignity of their own
experience so they can learn to solve
their own problems yeah so i don't know
i'm
i think that's always bad i think yeah
i've i've
i started therapy in new orleans when i
was like 18 i've been going on and off
for a long time it was like a weird
situation i mean it was like it was
right when katrina hit so it was like
the ninth ward you know and it was it it
was weird it was like it looked like
shutter island the hospital right went
uh
it looked it was abandoned so uh
this is perfect
well that was an issue i had to deal
with you know i had a very fortunate
situation like my i have a great dad but
i had a biological dad i just didn't
talk to so there was there was just you
adopted
no my mom raised the term is legally
adopted but i'm not like adopted a dog
that wasn't like in an orphanage i had a
great mom and she married a dad who's i
love my dad he's the best you know but i
have a biological dad who lives nine
blocks from me in new york so i would
like run into him on the street you know
and i was like yeah it's weird to just
see him and be like i'm gonna go that
way it's also weird to see your dad
every day he well he looks just like
like in your house
so that was weird but yeah he looks just
like you we look boy he's in his 80s but
yeah he looks just he's very old when
that happened
um it reminds me of the steve jobs story
of when he went to that restaurant where
his dad his biological father was a
waiter yeah and his dad waited on him
but he never told him yeah that's crazy
well i met him i met him i mean i've met
him how old were you when you met him 19
or 20 i was dating a girl who was like
both her parents were psychiatrists and
she was a little nuts and she
she would do shit in fights that was
like because she knew i'd never met him
so when we'd fight she'd be like she'd
be like who are you really yelling at
and i'd be like oh come on that's not
fair that's so that's not cool funny so
uh she was good at that so that i was
like yeah she's about to be available in
a writing capacity tv shows so i asked
my mom and she was like yeah he left a
safety deposit box for you and it was
like a note it was like a
typed up note uh he was like here's why
i did it and i'm sorry and uh
he was going through a lot of shit i i'm
not as angry as i was i was angry as a
kid just because i was like what the
hell i'm i'm cool why the hell would you
leave but uh
but i end up getting like a good deal
out of it my dad's a great dad yeah but
uh he and you got funny
you got trauma but well it's not really
try you know he was
he's an interesting guy i mean he's a
lot like me and like i do see i mean
some of the issues you're like well i
don't want to end up like him in any way
you know there's there's those issues so
it's weird to see the person who looks
physically most like you and you're like
yeah i've been to his place you know uh
his wife is really cool his wife is uh
his wife is a hairdresser and she toured
with cher and lily tomlin so i got to
like have dinner with lily tomlin a
couple times i'm like she's one of my
heroes i love her so um that's nuts yeah
she's she's a genius i love her um but
yeah so we
uh
it was weird i mean meeting him for sure
but then
you know it's you kind of just want to
know i've i've talked to people who like
have a similar situation like i don't
want to know and like what wanted to
know just for me you know right it's
it's
it's interesting to me i don't know yeah
we're biologically wired to want that
and um in your mom so you were raised by
her and the new guy when did he come in
he came in was like four and they got
married when i was like seven and so i i
kind of don't have a memory of any other
other way i mean he and he's such a
great dad mm-hmm
so um what do you do he's a lawyer he's
he he uh
he was kind of
pushed a little bit into early
retirement by his company so he started
his own arbitration firm and he's doing
well i mean he's he's a hustler he works
so hard i mean i love that i think a lot
of great comedians are worse i think
comedians are essentially lawyers right
you're arguing my brother and sister are
both lawyers see that's what i'm saying
so greg geraldo was a lawyer uh he was
one of them
like a lot of great because you're
basically arguing your case right so
it's like women are like cars that's not
true
i it's basically your honor hear me out
here just hold on it's basically you
take you say something that's not true
and then you prove it right
yeah exactly women are like exactly
women are like cars hear me out yeah
yeah they come in
three colors they're worth you know it's
500 a month to keep one and you should
only have them for two years like
whatever they lose their value the
second they whatever but they you know
they um
the who's the high-priced lawyer is
usually the defense right and the
defense is the harder argument right so
you kind of want to be the comedian who
makes the harder argument yes you're the
person that's like look he killed his
brother but like
let's be honest his brother did do this
and that like you know what i mean what
would you have done
totally like now you have to pay those
are the best bits i mean like those like
that's why i grew up on like chris rock
because it was always like this fucked
up setup and then the turn you'd be like
whoa that's it like that's kind of
interesting that a joke can do that
that's really what he does it's like i'm
gonna say something that is you've never
thought of that makes no sense and i'm
gonna make it
the like duh
yeah like i'm gonna make it true sure
it's like that magic trick so yeah
lawyers definitely do that so yeah it's
and then my mom is an artist so it was
like kind of like that that's amazing it
was that kind of and then you got that
work ethic my dad's lawyer yeah and um
and uh
and i love that shit and then um
so in therapy you're working on having
more empathy yeah and just being more
connected i think it's easy for me to
check out when things get you know asked
of me i'm very very my dad is very work
focused so i i definitely got that from
him you know that's a coping mechanism
though and it also serves you it's like
i just feel like there's you know in
12-step programs we call them um
character defects or superpowers like
there's certain things that are
pathologized by society that actually
like work for us like i went to um
this doctor we had in the podcast dr
david agus like i i i didn't really have
a doctor like i had like a gynecologist
many gynecologists your team yeah my
team of gynecologists
carpal tunnel uh digging out all the
random shit in there
and um and then i have a rheumatologist
that um i kind of use
for everything because i have like joint
stuff in my broken shoulder but i don't
have like a
what do you call him gj what's a general
doctor general practitioner like i don't
have like a gp and he was like you gotta
come down you gotta do like the sonogram
thing and i fake boobs so the sonograms
like a whole saga and um
and
he was asking he's like what's going on
how are you feeling because i get really
like chronic like migraines it's over
time with stuff and i was like you know
i just have like
anxiety and like i can't sleep so i'm
not you know and this and this and he
was like
is that
serving you at all like is that
necessarily a problem we want to solve
you know you're not sleeping not
sleeping well it's like this sounds like
a lazy doctor well it's like
are you getting work done are you you
know i don't i can't fall asleep till
two in the morning but that also because
doing that do you sleep in or do you
wake up early i can sleep in and then
nap i always nap between four and five
and like break up my days into two days
when i'm doing stand up so then it's
like i wake up and it's like you do your
first set but he was like okay but you
work till two in the morning isn't it
kind of good that you can't that you're
not tired at night like yeah you know
he's like don't conflate and let other
people pathologize certain things that
are serving you
also you have to understand our work
schedule is like nine to five they don't
go to sleep at six yeah yeah if you work
till 11 or 12 why would you go to sleep
at one yeah yeah totally but it's just
like for me and he was like let me let's
talk about the anxiety stuff like
anxiety is our body like giving us
valuable information sometimes it's like
i'm like i'm socially anxious
the people at this party suck and you
should leave because these people are
dangerous or not good for you or
whatever like it's you know i think
there's certain you know i have friends
that can't get out of bed with like
legitimate anxiety disorders but anxiety
in general is usually your body giving
you valuable information and if i had
listened to it earlier i would probably
have had a lot less like toxic
relationships
you know what i mean
yeah i mean it's
it's your body it's if if you're shaking
because something's making you feel bad
get the fuck out yeah also a lack of
empathy i think sometimes is a form of
energy conservation and
it is you sound like that guy's
therapist
actually having no empathy
you're do you have are you more bubbly
in the afternoon
i mean
i don't know
i believe we all have a finite set i
call them energy dollars a day
and you have to especially since we need
the most energy at night if you go
through the day having lunch with your
friends and then you stop some on the
street then you visit your aunt who's
sick and then this and this and you've
spent all your energy dollars like by
the time you
need to be attentive with taylor and
have like a focused conversation and
hear about her day and what's going on
or by the time you go on stage you're
like don't have anything left so we're
both time i mean we both do a lot i mean
that's just part of the road too is like
we're both tired sometimes i know but i
think but but empathy is very um
expensive energetically
so it could just i i definitely can like
shut down if i need to
and just go coffee helps yes
coffee helps my empathy
so you might be right energy is part of
it you know what i'm gonna ask you about
i'm gonna ask you about compromise
because i'm unwilling to compromise are
you yes and for the most part but you
and taylor are both on the road so much
we're both very busy so what do you do
do you schedule face times like do you
schedule we're very good actually we
what we do is um
we didn't used to do this but now on the
road a lot of times before bed we'll do
like well face time while we're watching
a show
so you can kind of have the corner of
the person and then you watch the show
in the other corner so i can like kind
of see a reaction it kind of feels like
watching the show
at home
okay is that weird
well if we're both in different cities
you know no it's it's you know what it
was a very judgmental look no no here's
why i like it here's why like well
because i know you're making your watch
mad mad and you're just watching all
these women
actually she wanted to watch it i bet
that was her pick and then okay it's not
like
sports or something no no the ones i i
always want to watch sopranos and she
can't do nothing violent before bed
really no thank you sex only there is
something wrong with me that i can watch
that shit there's literally a dude
getting his head caved in with a golf
club and i'm like
right i
drive you know the movie drive that
scene i am addicted to watching the
scene where he kicked that guy's head in
oh that was fun in the elevator yes
well first of all that slow how slow it
is he like kisses her and then does the
hottest thing i've ever seen totally
some of these action movies though
you're just kind of like it is hilarious
like i was just watching lethal weapon
the other day just like i haven't seen
this movie so i was a kid and it
literally opens with a woman and her
tits out and she jumps off a building
like this is the most actiony open ever
literally
big fake tits tits out shirt open jumps
to her like this could not be more made
for men
i'm obsessed with um
uh
foley artists um who make the sounds of
things in movies like they have got this
giant room
full of shoes and swords and vintage
guns and
fruit and watermelons and candy um glass
and stuff and they're the ones you go in
and they watch the movie and they take
two boots and they've got a giant mound
of gravel a giant mound of uh grass a
giant mound of dirt and they'll
make the sounds they'll have horse shoes
they'll do the whole thing that's wild
and there's an amazing video on how they
did the sound for that scene where he's
bashed his head in they took sugar glass
put it around a watermelon
and like he popped it with um
like a not a
what's not a spear but like a blunt kind
of pointy thing and had to try with a
bunch of different fruit but that was
the most close sound and then like a
neurologist will come in or neuroscience
and be like that's what a brain would
sound like if you squashed it exactly
like i love that you know what's so
weird is like the way we're always
thinking about jokes in a cafe he
probably hears the sound it's like i
could use that by the way isn't that
crazy can you do that again can you just
eating the banana pudding can you can
you do that one more time a hundred
percent obsessed the way you're chewing
that we could use it for a sex scene
yeah exactly let me say that queen can
you do that one more time
um but um
here's why i love it because i do think
i find uh when i'm trying to maintain a
relationship when i'm traveling a lot or
long distance when you face time there's
all this pressure
to be like
like yeah how was your day and how are
you feeling and to deliver and how to be
communicative there's nothing
sometimes of course i mean yeah a lot of
a relationship is just being next to a
person right and when you're traveling
all the time exactly so when you're
traveling all the time it takes a lot of
extra effort but you know you gotta you
kind of have to make that effort so
that's that's work on both of our parts
i mean i don't know i could just see
myself even making
like face timing watching a show like
like winding down stressful like it's
like something happens and you laugh i'm
like oh that was that funny oh you
thought it was funny when you pushed the
girl you think i'm gonna fucking scold
her oh you think seinfeld's a good show
okay sorry what's wrong with how do you
think she's pretty yeah
it's just like i don't think so yeah i
don't uh uh thank god that's a really
good idea
because
when you're on the road and you're
trying to just stay connected or trying
to just
a lot of times it's like people go in
with different expectations of what that
call should be and sometimes we have no
energy to give yeah i mean sometimes you
just face time and say good night but i
think when you're apart you want that
just checking for the most part she's
better at than i am but i know to check
in i know that's like important i know
to check in i know i think it's
important you know what is her love
language words of affirmation
no i think it's actions i don't think
it's words yeah yeah i think acts of
service i think i think words feel empty
without the actions yeah yeah 100 yeah
and i think to
yeah yeah people like us words are
actually
can be even more confusing if it's not
congress with your actions like i don't
want to hear the words i know you're
good with words you're a professional
comedian i'm that person like i don't
want to hear the words you know what i
mean um
but uh oh that's really yeah she hears
the word she's like that's a leonard
conley right that's bullshit
is that the monologue from labrum
you have no power over me like what
okay so what i want to know your top
five favorite movies favorite movies um
let me think uh out of the past is one
of them okay so these no one's gonna
know it okay do you want more modern
ones i don't know i'm just trying to get
to know you
great
i can watch it anytime do you love like
david lynch movies i saw blue velvet as
a kid i haven't seen a lot of david
lynch movies honestly yeah which is
weird because i know that he's like i
feel like these would be fun to watch
with your girlfriend on because they're
so open for interpretation they're great
to talk about to be like oh i thought
this was a symbolism for capitalism or
the p like i thought this was no i
didn't think that at all i thought it
was just a sex scene like
you either can read a ton it's like a
rorschach test she showed me i love yeah
i love that she showed me movies that
are like you know she loves singing in
the rain i've never seen that until her
i love that man you're both so old i
know we're old people you're like old
people maybe this is why you guys are so
depressed about the world is because you
think it's still like that you know
what's weird is that you should watch a
new movie those movies actually make me
optimistic in a weird way because those
the fact that they're still that they
stand the test of time almost 100 years
later makes me kind of optimistic about
the world oh that's nice yeah i love
that's why i love old movies i'm like
this was made
in the 40s and it's still good i mean
philadelphia's story is uh that's a
great movie that's her favorite i think
yeah that's weird
she loves philadelphia uh jimmy stewart
yeah but also your window i love all
those but it has the best um uh a line
that changed my life because i studied
like film in college that's like what i
studied and um and i think once you've
like done film
critique you like like can't it's not
fun to watch anymore because you're just
like overthinking it and then um but no
there was a line that um uh katherine
hepburn aka red or that's what cary
grant called in the movie um had which
is um
red you have no tolerance for human
weakness
and that it made me when i was like
frustrated with it my therapist said the
same thing to me
it's sad
that i i realize
i get insecure when someone
has some kind of weakness or insecure i
feel unsafe yeah and then i'm like and
it's a very primal reptilian thing of
like if there's a fire who's gonna
handle it like you know what i mean it's
a very fight-or-flight thing because i
grew up without a lot of you want to be
protected that's what it is and when
someone has a kind of weakness
myself having many but i i get
frustrated or when someone's insecure
it's like you can't doubt yourself like
we're in we're here we're this is life
motherfucker like i get frustrated but
it's also a good thing to think about
because i i think we glamorize by
accident we're just being authentic
and sometimes over sharing and just
being comedians but we tend to over
emphasize our limitations like i'm so
insecure i'm such a mess i'm such a
disaster because that's that's the
shortest way to a joke right completely
but in social situations it's just kind
of annoying and it's limiting well it's
also like i think you're great
and i'm what do you know about you right
you know what i mean you're stuck in
some version of yourself from the past
or what your dad said to you or your mom
did like i know you yeah and you're none
of those things like you know and this
is something that um i heard once from a
friend of mine's uncle randomly said
insecure people are dangerous
because an insecure person is the person
that's gonna
in another situation tell your secret to
try to get someone else's approval
mm-hmm like the insecure so when someone
well think about the words are insecure
right you break it down i mean you say
this house is insecure that's fucking
bad i'd like to get out of here the
miami condos were insecure so my thing
is if you're saying you're insecure
you're either trying to control me or
make me feel sorry for you
or if it's true i can't tell you any of
my secrets because you're insecure and
you'll do anything for other people's
approval
and it's also it's not a permanent state
like if you want self-esteem go do a
steamable action so if you're so
insecure and have low self-esteem that
means you're not doing sustainable
actions go take your neighbor's trash
out go get groceries for your
grandfather go do stuff that's going to
build up your self-esteem instead of
just talking about it but i think a lot
of people they brag about it because i'm
so insecure i'm like why are you saying
this as if you're on the cast of
insecurities yeah and it's like a bra
it's like a bragging point for them
you're like no it's not good you don't
get points for that you get points if
there's a funny joke you're right on
stage it's funny but in life like you
know great place to visit red flag don't
want to live here the only thing anyone
should be insecure about is not being
able to drive
what what is this power move uh i have a
license actually but i just can't i like
taylor let me drive her car once and she
was like absolutely not want to no i'm
terrible i'm really bad uh you could i
think i remember i did a road gig in
2010 i believe with joe list i don't
know if you know joe
joe yeah joe is my buddy and this was
like you know comes on the road with me
now he's a fucking murderer yes he's
hershberg who has um done a couple
cities with me
and he loves he loves touring with you
he has the funniest and the only kova
joke i even want to hear because after
co it was like coveted like we were just
all so sick of it and every comic is
talking about kovac i think like by a
couple months ago i was like okay let's
just talk about something else it's it's
such a mind fuck because it's like the
disease that has no symptoms and he's
like so i'd wake up every morning and be
like i feel great it's probably coving
that's great this is like
it's just such a good joke that i'm
butchering but he's he's great and he
deserves i this special i hope really
pops from because he deserves a bigger
audience he's so i mean i've known him
for years i agree but he's also like
it's the perfect time you know it's 34.
this whole thing where you make it at 22
is ronnie dangerfield made it 60 all the
greats
you know made it later when you're a
little more you get to enjoy it more
when you're young i mean the thing is
when you make it at 60 what do you have
20 years yeah but it's it's also there's
so much
bullshit comedy on twitter now that so
many things feel unoriginal just because
you know everyone that works in h r
block has one good tweet
so it's like people are seeing funny
shit on youtube they're seeing they can
see a you know
a panda dance to beyonce on youtube like
there's a you know and he's honing the
joke i mean i think if you put the work
in and you hone and you and you really
put karen in the material i i really do
i i'm so optimistic that you can have
this and to go you know what
it's fucking killing but that's a tweet
this joke's fucking killing it's just
not personal enough like his actor right
now is so
personal and i think he's digging even
deeper and i think for someone's first
special when when you're you want people
to turn off and go that guy's my friend
like i know that person like i want to
see them when they come to town that's
my buddy
yeah he's uh he puts to work in and he's
and he's a great writer yeah so i'm i
love he talks what's the weed the weed
cookie joke or like just have
uh like one bite of a weed cookie he's
like i've never taken one bite of a
cookie
it's just
it's just so funny
like just everything
and then the pee wee hormone joke really
pissed me off because he was like he
nailed it yeah because it's like you
know all these sexual predators are
showing their dicks and raping people yo
pee wee herman a big apology
he was in a theater like a gentleman in
the dark in a suit like in the back and
you're just like god damn it he's great
yeah the coolest yeah but why did i
bring that up i don't know where were we
um okay you're touring can we just um
uh now go watch all the specials and the
documentary i didn't want to talk about
them the entire time so that people got
to get to know you and you weren't
answering the same questions um but um
uh okay up on the roof and i got this
right up there and then uh full capacity
yeah they're on youtube and and they're
free and shit man i'm grateful for the
people that have watched and then your
last special is like they're your first
one that you put on youtube i got this
yeah right yeah if you haven't seen that
which i'm sure you have
amazing thank you um brilliant and also
your podcasts are you still having time
to do that i do i do we might be drunk
with mark normand
and i do a basketball one we were
definitely drunk with mark norman when
he was here i saw it it looked fun uh
you know and i do pod don't lie with
stavros so if you if you like basketball
but we uh that's where i get all my
basketball talk out but we do mark and i
would just we just get drunk
that is like i mean two of the funniest
people working right now um i hope you
move here one day i know it's never
gonna happen but i'm gonna try um and uh
i end these very awkwardly so apologies
and you're social he's got clips up of
when he's like touring on the road so
little mini specials coming out every
week on your instagram twitter
and um
i love you guys don't write elephants
[Music]
[Applause]